[Music]
in 2020 we got our first taste of
morbius but after a short delay
a long delay a medium-sized delay
a little bitty baby delay and one more
big fat delay for good measure audiences
everywhere are demanding
stop playing the morbius trailer every
time i see a film it's been two years
it's dr michael morvious at your service
no
more bs
meet michael morbius a doctor living
with a serious challenge being jared
leto
his search for a cure will take him from
the cave of wonders to his much hidden
very secret experiments i wouldn't go in
there if i were you
to sucking eight guys dry on a boat well
his girlfriend is asleep doesn't count
babe we're in international waters
jared leto plays a misunderstood genius
who's way too cool to accept the nobel
prize american scientist rejects
noble prize so of course he thinks this
character is based on his real persona
there's something uh
quite nice about that and the intimacy
of
sharing
who you are
uh with with with audiences once he
mixes bat with man he'll get all the
things you'd expect except kovid like
sonar
bat
abs
hollow little bones
and the ability to like force push bats
at your enemies with your mind
are we sure these are bad things but
these powers come with a catch now he's
thirsty for blood and instead of eating
animals that actual bats eat he'll go
straight for human juice forcing us to
watch him go to town on a blood bag
every few minutes of screen time
well this is just like camp when i found
out where they hit the capri suns
but mikey won't morb alone meet a
supporting cast whose backstory got cut
for time like tyrese a bland fbi agent
whose robot arm only appears in the
trailer in my head canon he's jax
martine a doctor whose only interesting
aspect gets punted to the sequel
anna a child morbius puts into a coma
and never visits again we have to induce
a coming hope she's feeling better and
jared harris a skilled thespian who
lends the fill much needed gravity and
he's dead
watch the good dr marvo take on the 11th
doctor milo matt smith acting with the
freedom of someone who realizes they're
in a train wreck so they might as well
have some fun while it goes totally off
the rails
when these vamps are on the hunt the
pg-13 action is so mild they won't even
bother to show it
but when these two pale boys finally
collide strap in for effects so honest
it looks like they added stink lines to
everyone to drive home how crappy it
looks
so after the success of no way home
enjoy sony's latest attempt to suck
every last drop of legally approved
continuity from the mcu like how about
the daily bugle huh that's a thing over
there maybe a venom reference he's in
both verses now right well we haven't
had anything this good since that thing
in san francisco hey look it's the
villain from two spider-mans ago that
doing anything for you no
what if we put a gun to his head and
made him read a script from bryce over
in marketing i'm not sure how i got here
has to do with spider-man i think i'm
still figuring this place out but i
think a bunch of guys like us should
team up you know i never thought that
this katana she's got my back could be
topped but bravo mr keaton bravo
starring
subway jared tyrese's polices
count white chocula
hi dr nick not another martine movie i'm
not sure how he got here has to do with
spider-man i think he's still figuring
this place out but i think guys like
them should team up and when mom won't
make tindies for dinner
[Applause]
i'm starting to get hungry
you don't want to see me when i'm hungry
you know i hate to say it but w was way
ahead of the morbius threat tonight i
ask you to pass legislation to prohibit
the most egregious abuses of medical
research creating human animal hybrids
okay maury is sucked but hopefully the
new season of stranger things won't
click the thumbnail on the right to
craft seasons one through three over on
phantom entertainment oh and by the way
we're finally out of our disgusting
bedrooms and back in the studio check
out honest trailer commentaries in the
thumbnail on the left and more about
even more we even hide a movie fight in
every episode